[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace andino desde Bogotá
es una de las historias del año el
presidente de Colombia Gustavo petrol la
ha calificado de mágica Leslie de 13
años solem de 9 p.m de 5 y Christine D1
son cuatro niños indígenas
sobrevivientes por partida doble
[Música]
el primero de mayo sobrevivieron a un
accidente de avioneta en el que murieron
su madre y otros dos adultos después de
un fallo mecánico en la avioneta el
piloto trató de aterrizar sobre los
altos árboles de las selvas de Colombia
Harvey Gómez joven de la misma comunidad
que los niños le contó a France 24 desde
San José del guaviare Cómo fue el
hallazgo de la avioneta dos semanas
después del accidente muchacho que iba
delante mío me dijo
Mira una casa yo le digo yo lo que
mirando y la avionetas a yo fui
corriendo y miré los pedazos desplomados
yo estaba las alas por acá Había otro
pedazo
yo me acerqué tanto y que eso tenía
muchas moscas
estaba lleno
y había muchos Buitres a veces
rondeando el lugar después los niños
estuvieron 40 días perdidos en la selva
hasta que fueron encontrados el 9 de
junio una interminable espera
especialmente para la familia materna
que Ahora pide la custodia no confían en
el padre de los dos menores O sea si la
niña no tiene confianza Ahora peor
nosotros porque ellos son los que saben
ellos son los que han vivido o sea
muchas veces uno uno quisiera pedirlo
pero la todo la palabra la última
palabra desde la decisión lo tiene la
niña grande
porque ella sabe ella actúa y usted sabe
que los derechos de los niños hay que
respetarlo
de operación Esperanza a operación
milagro el lema fue buscarlos hasta
encontrarlos participaron más de 200
personas entre fuerzas armadas e
indígenas una Unión de saberes
ancestrales y militares claves para el
éxito en una unión inédita para
encontrar a los niños se usaron todo
tipo de técnicas mensajes de audio en
lengua indígena de la abuela cuerda
silbatos y hasta el lanzamiento de
flyers y kits de alimentación los niños
se encontraron uno de estos y pudieron
alimentarse de fariña un derivado de la
yuca típico en las comunidades indígenas
también se hicieron refugios
improvisados y utilizaron objetos que
quedaron en el avión siniestrado
perdidos Sí pero en su propio hábitat en
la selva donde parte de su aprendizaje
vital consiste en saber utilizar sus
recursos infinitos
la historia se popularizó el 17 de mayo
cuando el presidente de Colombia Gustavo
Petro tuiteó que los niños habían
aparecido con vida Un día después borró
el tuit y escribió una disculpa He
decidido Borrar el trino debido a que la
información entregada por el icbf no ha
podido ser confirmada lamentó lo
sucedido las fuerzas militares y las
comunidades indígenas continuarán en su
búsqueda incansable para darle al país
la noticia que está esperando en este
momento no hay otra prioridad diferente
a la de avanzar con la búsqueda hasta
encontrarlos la vida de los niños es lo
más importante la directora del
instituto colombiano de bienestar
familiar es Astrid Cáceres quien ha
estado liderando la operación de rescate
para ella a este tuit acabó
convirtiéndose en un importante mensaje
para la infancia de Colombia estando
allá entonces ya las familias nos dicen
Bueno pues gracias al trino llegó más
ayuda y vino más gente entonces creo que
eso posicionó en un lugar adecuado la
búsqueda de cuatro niños indígenas que
de otra manera hubiera podido pasar
dentro de los rangos de búsqueda
normales que hace un país para estos
casos no la misión de Astrid Cáceres es
la de cuidar de la infancia de Colombia
un país en el que hay más de un 50% de
pobreza infantil en el que hay más de
200 casos de reclutamiento forzado por
parte de grupos armados de niños en 2023
y en el que además hay más de 3.600
niños a la espera de una familia de
adopción la custodia de los niños
indígenas por el momento estará en manos
del instituto colombiano de bienestar
familiar seguirán todos los
requerimientos indígenas mientras duren
Las investigaciones pero el Gobierno ya
ha asegurado que les va a prometer y
garantizar educación gratuita son tres
defensorías a cargo para mirar y está
toda una comunidad que trabaja en una
mesa de coordinación con las
organizaciones amazónicas para que el
tema cultural no se pierda entonces de
alguna manera van a tener que tomarse
para que los niños estén en condiciones
de bienestar pero donde se tome la
decisión pues todo el el combo de
protección estará pendiente de ellos no
nosotros esperamos Que tengan
oportunidades educativas Libertad para
vivir su cultura pero también todo el
amor y la confianza y la protección que
les dé seguridad para seguir adelante
Leslie solé Cristina ya son un símbolo
para Colombia sus relatos de esos 40
días en la selva ya son parte de la
historia de Colombia y serán retratados
en películas libros e informes como este
Pueden seguir más contenidos como este
enlace andino desde Bogotá en France 24
y France 24.com
[Música]